our president will start a war with Iran
because he has absolutely no ability to
negotiate he's weak and he's ineffective
so the only way he figures that he's
going to get reelected and as sure as
you sitting there is to start a war with
Iran
this is a great time to negotiate
unfortunately we have a president that
doesn't know the first thing about
negotiations in a few moments I'll be
signing an executive order imposing
hard-hitting sanctions on the supreme
leader of Iran and the office of the
Supreme Leader of Iran and many others
these measures represent a strong and
proportionate response to Iran's
increasingly provocative actions we will
continue to increase pressure on
terrorists until the regime abandons its
dangerous activities and aspirations
including the pursuit of nuclear weapons
increased enrichment of uranium
development of ballistic missiles
engagement in and support for terrorism